born to do something great and it's high
time the world started to speak this way
to each other that we loved each other
that we supported each other and that
human beings know they were born for a
reason which is to do something awesome
in little ways and big ways with their
life right or wrong
ed mylett is one of the world's best
business leaders peak performance
experts and motivational speakers
millions of people they listen to his
podcast and he has a new book called the
power of one more the ultimate guide to
happiness and success and he joins us
now and thanks for coming on the show
buddy man i'm so glad to see you in
person it's great to be here i am
thrilled to meet you i've been following
you for years i've read your books
listened to the podcast you have had
such a positive effect on my life and
i'm going to start i'm going to start
here okay i met you earlier thank you so
much for everything you do my friend oh
man it's my honor it's so great to you
know hear that from you that's why i do
the work so thank you man let's talk
about the book what is the power of one
more well really probably has two
applications one is that i think in life
you're much closer to what you want in
your life your vision and your dreams
than you think you are most people think
it's 20 30 years away because they think
that they act in accordance with this
mindset with this belief system and they
perpetually keep things that far away
but the truth is you're one decision one
relationship one new meeting one
encounter one podcast one book one new
thought one new emotion from changing
your life so that's the first power the
second power is
that in life if you're gonna really
change things you have to change your
standard and so the standard needs to be
one more if you say you're gonna get up
and you're gonna do 10 reps on the bench
press do 10 plus one more you're going
to tell your daughter you love her every
day do it tell her one more time if you
start stacking up those one mores in
life you start to transform your life by
doing that it applies to all aspects of
your life one thing you talk about in
the book is self-confidence for people
watching right now what's one thing that
we can do starting right now to help
improve our self-confidence start
keeping small promises you make to
yourself so self-confidence is actually
a relationship or reputation that you
have with you and if you lack
self-confidence like i have in my life
it's because i didn't keep the promises
i made to myself so start with small
things what time you're going to get up
in the morning how much water you're
going to drink what you're going to eat
every day make your bed it may sound
very simple but when you start that
reputation with you with small things
then you can point your mind like a
weapon at big things and you have the
confidence that you do what you say
you're going to do that's so good it's
so good so we're going to have
confidence up here this high but there's
still that negative voice the negative
soundtrack that we hear all the time how
do you fight that how do you fight the
negative voice that that people have all
the time well i call that the matrix
there's this thing in your brain called
the reticular activating system and it's
actually your filter of your life and so
it reveals to you that which you most
truly believe and so what we do is we
need to start to you already visualize
just most people visualize their fears
their anxieties their worries and so
they move towards it we move towards
what we're most familiar with so if you
would just take the time and start to be
intentional give yourself the gift one
minute a day of dreaming of visualizing
what it is you do want you actually
begin to trick your mind into moving
towards what you're familiar with
because that becomes your dominant
thought you're changing lives during
this interview you're giving me
goosebumps listen to this i've read the
book i've listened to the book as well
there's a part of the book where you
talk about dreaming and how as adults we
need to keep on dreaming well here's the
truth there's two operating systems in
life 99 of people operate out of history
and memory
one percent operate out of imagination
or vision or dreams and so why when
we're a child why are we happier i
believe we're happier because we're just
more recently with god but also we have
no history or memory so we imagine by
default and then as some ages even 10 12
15 20 years old we default into memory
and history and we begin to repeat those
thoughts those emotions and our life
just becomes a pattern of those things
so you have to wrestle that away and
begin to imagine and dream and it seems
hokey at first right but just remember
this when you have a new thought just
any thought
imagine something it creates a space in
the world that didn't exist before you
had that thought and what happens is you
and the world conspire and god to fill
that room up with the things requisite
to make it a reality so imagination and
vision is the one percent of happy and
successful people ahead i love it how
can people get more find the book you
have a tv show coming out on nbc how can
people get more uh any uh edm led
anywhere e d m y l e t t you get the
book anywhere in the world uh instagram
social media youtube podcast i'm pretty
much everywhere right now i love it
thank you so much my friend this has
been an absolute honor and a thrill
thank you my privilege brother allison
thank you
wow